we rely on Rudy you may know us as food
boost GQ sent us around the country to
find the coolest bars and restaurants
when you're a Minneapolis check out the
North Loop here are some cool places to
go at dusk we arrived at spoon and
stable and met the bartender Nathaniel
start off the night with a daiquiri shot
so weird the bartender's new around here
apparently after our daiquiri shots we
walked across the street to this
clothing store called ask off Finlayson
a pretty cool little store that sells a
bunch of North gear we got some hats cuz
our heads are cold we played mini hockey
and I beat Nathaniel ass but then we
found out the guy who owns this place
also owns the place next door so we
invited us over for a martini at this
place called bachelor farmer first they
gave us an awesome martini which is
delicious at this place they have this
really cool thing where you can draw
something or write something in a
moleskin notebook I wrote a note to my
mom and stuck it on the wall
Nathaniel told us about his hidden
speakeasy downstairs called marvel bar
someone punched in a little key code and
the door opened up if you're hungry this
serves super-sweet bar snacks Cheetos he
made a special drink sticky tape egg
white and required an excessive amount
of shaking the end result was pretty
cool and tasted pretty bomb so after
marvel bar the family wanted to show us
where he started bartending
that's where saffron comes in we came in
here and eat sheep brains and all types
of really cool stuff the lamb BLT was
the best BLT I've ever had I don't
remember what these fried little balls
were but they were amazing he also gave
us these really cool shots of autop
alright cos in a nice flavor and alcohol
you mix it with water and it turns white
after we had a bunch of food we walked
to an automated bicycle rental kiosk
every fat man's worst nightmare we
headed over the Mississippi River whoa
this is hard wrote their neighborhoods
up hills down hills a lot of fun we took
our bikes back and everybody took off
come to Minneapolis and check out the
North Loop here are some places you need
to hit if you think we're way off
send us your favorite spots